the first thing you notice when you slip
behind the wheel of the BMW i3 is how
superior you feel physically and morally
first of all even though it's a small
car the seat is deceptively high
certainly above the one in its big
brother the iead supercar the i3 doesn't
feel at all muscley engine wise but the
power trip you get from sitting higher
than expected is worth noting and as for
its moral superiority that comes from
the cars electric battery which gets
seventy miles per charge
you're not just driving in high style
you're saving the world and it will cost
you less than $50,000 here's what you
need to know the car was launched in
2013 as part of BMWs electric range of
cars which they call the I program the
version I drove has an all-electric 170
horsepower motor paired with a range
extending two cylinder engine
combine them and you'll get about 117
miles per gallon you can plug it into
any outlet like you would plug in a
vacuum but using the fast charging
station that BMW also sells really
speeds things up on average it takes
four hours to recharge fully the i3 is
silent as it runs and it's very smooth
to drive but don't plan on winning any
drag races in this thing it takes seven
seconds to hit 60 miles per hour and it
has a max speed of barely over 90 miles
per hour slowing down in the i3 is
pretty rough too the minute you take
your foot off the gas the car basically
stops you feel like you're braking but
you're not in fact braking seems almost
redundant at this point driving in
comfort mode makes it feel smoother but
that reduces the battery charge by half
the interior of the carbon-fiber
passenger shell feels spacious if a
little flat I like the gray wool cloth
seats paired with faux bamboo now we've
got to talk about something that is not
as shallow as it seems how this car
looks to which I answer not great
remember the i8 with its futuristic
angled doors swooping fenders and
muscular haunches it looks so cool the
i3 is the opposite of that it's tall and
boxy and its rear doors open bizarrely
backwards is there a rule that says
smaller less expensive electric cars
have to look weird I don't get it I
guess if you're saving the world you
just don't care what you look like